building the conversation of what would
happen if you are trying to make a
reservation will not stay on top Fionan
yes for dinner at least around them at
the restaurant vicino openin so we enter
the phone by saying ready ready ready
that mean what what is ready Italian
Bravo yes oh let's say you're calling
and then the restaurant is says pronto
ready and then they say I say the
sentence and you go let's say that
you're calling a given restaurants ready
oh so this is a spelling challenge they
say pronto ristorante done on nokia and
you sign it's okay mr. on tell me what
we slammed belong appiah oh yeah I
restaurant wanna say do they make
ristorante to write nice what are they
so what they say mr. after that were
run and then name the restaurant is
Raffy good name so you start with da
cheese bye Nona that's right yeah
grandma very good yeah so forgive me I
would like to bring up a tech wizard
friend no at table
for tomorrow evening go
okay motive oh but I have punctuation
buona sera breathing come on wanna say
one word are you inviting separated are
you famous now hear you say Molly yo one
is not very time because it's like my
budget I was like oh hey thanks ray all
right bring italia for it then yes both
una cabra in Punta below are correct oh
okay um Pablo is more common but wrap
our would-be self correct so Tom and
come on inside close to the window
translation and you say it's okay and
that second part is from the translation
from Italian you ask check una bella
vista from deep yeah oh my god oh my god
father I'm sorry babe and what was the
thing oh yeah it's very nice to give you
okay now let's do the last part of the
conversation they answer to you they say
yes then you answer oh then it's okay
let me ask you let's watch me humans
with very yummy okay so they say you
they say yes you say then it's okay they
ask you a personal and you say finish
yummy and then hey thank you oh there
with you so they can you see see yes
don't you say then
okay okay Norman and your name of your
last thing goes a bit shiny white
philosophies to say to me but its young
yeah but it's yummy it's me yeah it's
yeah it's very shiny sure it's a little
bit warmer so spinning the Attic they
named Johnny you feel different but it's
danny i show you some people from Bonita
right open it Tiana which means I come
from an ocean and then grab said vedecci
we need to write it down post already
know today last challenge so you finally
managed to make a lot to a prenup
acciona and we arrived are surrounded
write it down to salem center all i
wanted to translated from english to
italian i have a reservation for 15 at
the name with Chani rocky yeah
no and we will reach it you can say a
normal or abnormal and that was fine
perfect so you know how to make your
reservations on